[Music]
let's go to angela on the streets of
laredo what's up angela
hello dr john how are you well i'm
partying that's not true i'm not
partying i'm hanging out what's up what
are you up to
well i'm just getting out of work right
now heading home and it's about 100 plus
degrees here so
i had a fan in front of me right now but
jenna couldn't hear me so i had to turn
it down too hot
super hot over here
you got that right all right so what's
up
well i um am about i'm in my mid 40s and
i was married for almost 20 years and
then i was divorced and uh what happened
now i'm in then oh
that's gonna take another call oh okay
all right all right
uh in in long long story short my
ex-husband uh committed a federal crime
and i had to separate from him
that is hey you know what wrapped up
right there with a bow on it that's all
we need to talk exactly all right
exactly um and i burned the letter
already so you know the last ball hit
the nail on the head on that part let me
tell you
good so all right so
we've turned the letter we're on to the
new one right um to the new and correct
and um he's a wonderful wonderful man we
have been in a relationship for almost
four years
um the problem is that i am a social
butterfly and i enjoy going out i enjoy
meeting new people
um i enjoy dancing and
he doesn't
and we went to a gathering about a week
and a half ago and i had to prep him for
it so to speak
and um we were going to sit with some
friends of ours and turns out the table
was short was smaller rather
rather smaller than we thought so we
wound up sitting with strangers which i
was fine with
but he was he was very nervous about it
and he said i think i want to leave and
he said but i'm not
um but i think i want to and i was like
you're okay don't worry about anything
and you know the night continued but
later on he did tell me you know like
there's times that i do want to just get
up and go
um and
i
feel like this is a very serious
relationship i wouldn't have given it
three years of my life if i didn't think
it was
um
but what i'm worried about is how do we
continue because
i love being social and he is a
he's a big introvert he's the only male
child and he's got about six sisters
so
i don't
exactly i feel like he
no never had the chance to speak he was
always around a bunch of girls
um all right so
let's take introvert and extrovert off
the table
okay here's why
those labels end up
conflating a lot of things giving a lot
of excuses and a lot of blah blah blah
let's take that off i agree
okay let's go down to very simple
here's what i need to be in a
relationship with you
and vice versa
tell me what you need to be in
relationship with me
and what we are going to do
is spend the rest of our lives working
to meet the other person's needs
so here's an example in my house
um
i take silence as rejection i don't know
why i just do
when i walk by a person in new york city
on the sidewalk and i say hey what's up
and they look at you like crazy or worse
they just act like you didn't say
anything
my first thought is what did i do what's
wrong hey let's go talk i'll buy the
first round are you okay right that's
just my body takes off that way
when that happens in my home
it sets off some sort of rejection alarm
that i fully don't understand
and you mirror that with
my wife likes silence in the morning
don't talk
can we just wake up slowly and quietly
and read and write and have coffee and
watch the sun come up
and listen to the birds and i want to
talk and sing and have conversations
let's have a party hey let's get the
band together let's have a house party
at 5 45 a.m
that is me right
so what we had to do in our house
is
sit down and say what do you need
and i said and it was hard for me to say
this because i'm supposed to be a big
tough texas male
i said i need you to say good morning
and just give me a hug
i need that anchor point in my day if i
don't get that anchor point i'm all over
the place
and she said
done
and
she needs
space in the mornings that is just hers
for her to slowly on ramp the day
that includes writing and reading and
meditating and reflecting and all those
things
and so i moved my workout time from the
evening to the mornings
that automatic boom an hour separation
right there
and so
you see what i'm saying so we both sat
down and said we love each other
and i have this need and you have this
need how can we work to make each of to
meet each other's needs and i had to
learn i can't have a disco at 5 45.
and she had to learn she can't have
complete and utter silence because she
doesn't live in a monastery
and both of us made peace so what i'm
telling you is this what i would love to
see you and this guy who might be your
your forever
guy
sit down and say okay we've been
together for three years
you have some needs that i'm not meeting
or that are new or that are changing or
whatever
what needs do you have
and vice versa here's the needs i have
i need to go dancing once or twice a
month
i need that and i want that to be with
you
i need you to be seen in public i need
you to smile in public i need to have
this joy out there
and he might say i need silence too
and so i agree cool i am going to make
peace with sitting down on the couch and
snuggling up with a pizza and whatever
the thing is you hear what i'm saying
correct yes
so let's approach it with what do you
need
and what are you willing to do what are
you willing to invest in this thing
and he might tell you i need you to
never ask me to go dancing again because
i'm never going
and i would tell you don't marry that
guy
hey cause that's not about dancing
that's about him looking you in the eye
and saying i don't care what your needs
are mine are more important
right i want someone who says i hate
dancing
i don't like it it makes me feel exposed
and i'm gonna go figure it out
which is exactly what happened the other
night he said i wanted to leave but i
stayed because
i wanted i knew you were having fun and
i love you and so i wanted to stay
because you were happy excellent but he
did tell me the other day he was you
know dying on the inside that entire
time
at some point
that's a choice
at some point he can choose like
here's a great example i agreed to go i
was talking about this beginning of the
show i agreed to go skydiving tomorrow
with dave ramsey a couple of friends
it's my number one fear on the planet
i'm about 98 sure this is the last phone
call ever taken my whole career right
now this is it well you picked a great
one i did i got really lucky um
but i said i would go and so when i said
i would go i now have two choices
i can
go all in and be like dude this is going
to be crazy and fun and i'm going to
smile about it i'm going to be like ah
or
i can curl up in a ball and be like
we're going to die we're going to die
we're going to die i get to choose which
one of those we're going to do
that i'm going to do you know what i
mean i get to live into the reality that
i've accepted
correct okay
he is he has chosen you
and you are a person that goes dancing
and so since he's going to be with
somebody who goes dancing that means
he's going to go dancing
and then he gets to choose am i going to
be dead inside
or am i going to sneak off and i'm going
to start taking dance lessons
or maybe if you offered him i need to go
dancing and i know you're uncomfortable
i signed us up for for dance lessons
and we're going to do that instead of
going to the gym it's going to be good
at work out blah blah blah we're going
to do that together see what i'm saying
yes
but yeah
i've talked a lot
come get back to this
what are your needs
and here are my needs and how can i work
to
help you meet your needs so that you can
work and help me meet my needs and we're
just going to make a loop an infinity
loop over and over for the rest of our
lives and those needs are going to shift
and change and move so we're going to
check in every couple of months every
couple of um every six months
once twice a year we're going to keep
checking with it what are your needs now
what do you need in this season what do
you need in this season i'm going to
make that happen
and if he says i'll go dancing but i'll
be dead inside
some of that is just texas nonsensical
bravado you know that you know yes but
some of that is a choice and maybe you
say i need you to choose
that when we go dancing
that you're gonna have fun make that
choice for me
choose to have fun i can't choose to
have fun yes you can
you can
i've ended up in places where i'm like
i'm just going to cut loose and i end up
acting like a clown and it's funny and
it's silly and i have a great time and i
go home and i'm grumpy about it it was
not that bad
you know what i mean
yes i know i wasn't and i've also sat at
tables and thought
i would rather set my face on fire than
continue sitting here
and that is a choice that i make
not the table
you got it see what i'm saying yes and
you
angela
may have to spend
a couple of nights watching movies or
laying low
or saying you need some quiet
rejuvenating time
go spend time hunting with your buddies
go spend time fill in the blank go work
on your dad's car whatever the thing is
i don't know what he's into go play
don't don't play golf absolutely don't
play golf i don't know what he's into
but
i'm gonna i'm gonna support you in those
endeavors because i know you need that
and when you get a couple who tries to
meet each other's needs out meet each
other's needs
and he's trying to outmeet your needs
and you're trying to meet his needs
that's a marriage that is built to last
that is a love that will continue and
continue despite everything in in
because of everything
that's one that's going to keep going
and keep going and keep going because
it's not about what about me and it's
not about i need you to it's about how
can i meet your needs so that you can
meet mine